okay everyone Avengers infinity war
ended with a real shocker and one last
spoiler warning guys you really have had
plenty of time to see it Danis actually
uses the Infinity Gauntlet to snap away
half the universe and to break the
hearts of everyone who loves spider-man
and Black Panther and the one guy who's
really a mantis but if you were watching
closely
right after Thinnes returns from Seoul
world and zips away from Thor the post
snap Infinity Gauntlet looks cracked and
smoky and overcooked
now there's some debate over whether or
not you could see tannaz wearing the
gauntlet later but leave in the final
shot movie but you if you were looking
more closely you can kind of see
thinnest his armor hanging up off to the
side
so he does have some of the stuff it's a
nod to the Infinity Gauntlet comics
where Thanos retires on a farm and hangs
up his armor on a scarecrow it's kind of
fun but that this smokey shot brings up
a question is the Infinity Gauntlet
broken
now of course Stannis could still open
up a portal a portal and escape from
Thor which required the space stone but
can he use the Infinity stones in
combination ever again it mess up his
arm pretty bad it looked like even like
above it yeah you point out something
interesting there cuz when you look at
the movie it's like why are we spending
so much time on Thor getting another
hammer like yeah that feels like a real
like just something we could like
streamlined as entertaining as it is
because I like for with rocket and Groot
but maybe we find out that the people
that built the hammer also built the
gauntlet so maybe the stones are fine
but we need another mechanism which
actually looks like there was one
sitting there another mechanism to use
it maybe that's why they went through
the trouble of introducing it because
it'll matter in the next movie yeah I
think I'm not sure on this but I feel
like the thing that we see there is the
mold yeah for the gauntlet that they do
make but I do think that also means like
we could make another one but I think
Eric's point is the one that I'm abiding
by right now they can't right now in its
current state it can't do it again
yeah yeah that's maybe one one time can
be used but the idea of putting the
Power Stone behind the you know like the
I guess the soul stone maybe it's one
that's like wiping the universe out of
it over but the thing that is enhancing
the other ones
that's probably what broke it and
overloaded it yeah yeah yeah the stones
can't be used in tandem like we saw in
some of the battles like he's using both
the reality stone and the space stone at
the same time or
he'll use the space don't like phase
shift Hulk into a mountain and the power
soda like punch Captain America out of
the way he can't do these things at the
same time at least anymore and arguably
the stones could be separated now
theoretically and I would argue that I
do think it's got to be relevant that we
saw it so damaged because from a writing
perspective that's a fascinating
situation to put yourselves in as the
Russo brothers another brother team the
Coen brothers famously had this rule
where they would write a situation for
their characters that was so difficult
to figure out how they're gonna solve
this that if they could as the writers
come up with a solution within two weeks
they were like well then this isn't hard
enough oh I'll make it even worse on
their characters so I feel like the idea
that we're all like oh well you could
just get the gauntlet off his arm and do
it they're like okay so let's break the
gauntlet like let's give ourselves as
many problems as we can just so that in
this year that we have of waiting none
of us are like I know how he does it you
know what you know it's 100% gonna be
there it's gonna be their version yeah
it's gonna be the they're gonna
introduce a version of the infinity
watch like how many Avengers are left
from the original team six yeah each one
gets a stone they have to use it in
tandem to undo the things so they push
the beams together and then so that
might not be it but it wouldn't surprise
me if this is the mechanism that they
used to introduce something close to
infinity watch and it would be these
characters because a lot of them and
they're not going to keep paying Robert
Downey jr. the money they're paying yeah
you can you just can you explain what
the reference is so in the comics
because the Infinity stones are so
dangerous when brought together the
either divided up against amongst a
group of cosmic individuals most of
which we haven't seen Drax and Gamora in
there Adam warlock as a part of it you
might have heard about him in talks with
guardians and then moon dragon which is
a version of Drax is daughter Oh which
is it's more lifting if you go into like
sixties seventies cosmic Marvel it's
super confusing actually
adapt that to another team really but
that people want is Illuminati because
they did the same thing yeah little
taste of Illuminati and some
conversations in the sub like I was like
oh I love these potential conversations
yeah in in one of the Avengers team
because there's they always like revamp
it every couple months but you find out
that Black Bolt Professor X Doctor
Strange another Iron Man and a couple
other like big leaders for different
teams and Marvel hit Infinity stones in
different places but mostly on earth
which was not a great idea in that story
but it does make it very interesting so
you could get like a version yeah that
way now make more sense with the
characters we've been introduced to yeah
yeah so in that scenario would be what
Black Panther Tony Stark Doctor Strange
after they've used it yeah theoretically
have to fix everything yeah although I
do think I would I would be shocked if
we come out of this movie with both Iron
Man and cap fine I think can I think
caps done both like have such good
reasons to leave at this point yeah jr.
seems like he likes it more but I think
what's good to point out it's not only
is the Infinity Gauntlet looking fried
and broken meaning that they can't do
another snap it means to me that this
can't be reversed that simply it's not
like this is but if this was a light
switch it couldn't be flipped back off
yeah so I think it is critical not just
like oh the threat is over but like the
way to fix the threat or reverse the
threat is no longer an option it's gonna
take at least three hours to figure out
yeah and like 20 meteors that the one
person ant-man and Captain Marvel
probably well let us know what your
theories about the status of the
Infinity Gauntlet are in the comments
below and and what different
implications it being possibly broken
are and a reminder reminder to like this
video subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our Infinity Ward deep dives
thanks everybody